face à la nouvelle vague du coc vie 19
l'europe a décidé de serrer la vis dans
la ligne de mire des autorités
européennes
le variant du virus découvert au
royaume-uni largement touchés londres
veut accélérer son plan de vaccination
alors que 2,3 millions de britanniques
sont déjà vaccinés
le pays s'est fixé un nouvel objectif
les 14 millions de personnes à risques
d'ici la fin du mois de février
en plus du plan de vaccination
l'angleterre compte sur un confinement
strict pour freiner la progression du
virus la ministre de l'intérieur
britannique a averti ce mardi des
conséquences du non-respect du
confinement une minorité de personnes
mettent en danger la santé de la nation
en ne respectant pas les règles
c'est pourquoi le secrétaire d'état aux
collectivités locales a parlé
aujourd'hui aux conseils locaux du rôle
qu'ils ont à jouer pour faire respecter
les règles et sauver des vies et nos
agents de police seront désormais plus
rapide pour infliger des amendes
lorsque des personnes enfreignent
clairement la réglementation concernant
le coronavirus un confinement strict
adopté par d'autres pays européens
outre la grèce et le danemark
l'allemagne opte également pour cette
solution depuis le 15 décembre dernier
la chancelière allemande angela merkel
estime à ce propos que le pays pourrait
garder cette mesure jusqu'au mois
d'avril
si la situation sanitaire ne s'améliore
pas un confinement également prolongé
aux pays bas où le nombre de
contaminations reste élevé malgré les
restrictions des mesure décriée par
certains professionnels du tourisme en
détresse financière face à la crise
sanitaire
à rome ils étaient des centaines
rassemblés pour demander au gouvernement
d'écouter leurs préoccupations nous
demandons à être écoutés parce que nous
avons été oubliés à nouveau
nous avons d'abord eu un peu
d'interaction avec le gouvernement mais
maintenant nous avons été à nouveau
abandonné
nous attendons des réponses depuis le
mois de juillet nous avons eu une baisse
de 100 %
mon agence est fermé depuis le 11 mars
comme toutes les autres agences de
voyages nous parlons de dizaines de
milliers d'euros de revenus en moins
peut-être que si nous nous mettons tous
ensemble c'est des millions d'euros de
pertes
demandant à travailler simplement à
travailler
nous voulons créer des couloirs de santé
qui permettrait à nos clients de voyager
les gens veulent voyager une lassitude
exprimée dans d'autres pays européens
en suisse pas moins de 300 commerçants
ont décidé ce lundi de ne plus respecter
les restrictions et d'ouvrir leurs
portes aux clients pour sauver leur
entreprise
face au regain du virus l'europe semble
pourtant bien loin de vouloir assouplir
ses restrictions